(audience clapping)
- Oh my gosh.
Have y'all ever met?
Cara, have y'all ever met?
- We have not.
- No.
- You have not.
Okay.
- It's my loss, obviously.
- In my dreams.
I know.
I don't stare too long.
- No, in my dreams.
- You start forgetting anything,
you just look at her eyes.
It's crazy.
It's a magical power.
- Yeah, they're quiet lovely.
- And then she'll guess what you're using.
You, you've got like a
blue hue around yours.
- Do I?
- [Kelly] Navy blue?
- Maybe it's the orange
that's reflecting off.
It could be that.
Could be that.
- [Kelly] Is that the accent as well.
- You should be a model.
- [Kelly] Yeah, right?
- She should be a model.
You can get into that maybe,
and win awards for it.
So are you amazed with how much,
I mean people still love 'The Notebook.'
It's just one of the most
gigantic love stories of all.
Did you know, did you have an inkling
that this is gonna connect
when you were writing it?
It's hard to say, I guess now, but.
- You know, when I was writing it,
I thought it had a chance.
It was funny.
You know, it was a story
originally inspired by my
wife at the time, Kathy,
her grandparents.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And you know, I remember seeing how much
they cared for each other
toward the end of their life.
And it was a story that moved me.
And as I'm there typing,
I hoped people would get it.
But one never knows, right?
- You don't, yeah.
- I had no agent.
I knew nothing about
publishing at the time.
- Wow.
Geez.
- What?
- Yeah.
- I didn't know that, man.
I was working full-time.
And then we had a young baby at the times
who didn't sleep well.
So I had time in the evening to write
since Kathy would go to sleep.
So I wrote 'The Notebook' in my spare time.
- In your spare time.
- Yeah.
(audience laughing)
- Just wrote 'The Notebook.'
It's fine.
So have you ever wanted to
do anything besides writing?
Is there any other like
vocation or hobby that you love?
- Yeah.
Well, sure you have what you think about
when you're a kid, right?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- You'll be an astronaut.
I thought that would be pretty
neat to be an astronaut.
- Hell yeah, that's cool.
- Right?
- Yeah.
And there was a time I wanted to be
like an Olympic gold
medalist or a famous athlete.
I thought that would be-
- Dreaming small.
- A pretty good.
- You dream small.
- [Kelly] I'm like, you dream big.
- Yeah.
But I didn't have the talent
on the one hand, and you know,
the whole science thing on
the other didn't work out.
So, it's hard to tell.
You know, I started writing,
I think I wrote my first novel at 19.
- [Cara] Wow.
- [Kelly] Wow.
- And then it was never published.
Wrote a second one at 22.
It was never published.
- See that's good for
writers to hear, I think.
'Cause I think people think everything
is an overnight success, and it's not.
You do have to grind a bit.
Even if people don't see that
and they only see you when you start.
- I would agree.
- Yeah.
You have to learn your craft, right?
- And so did that.
And then when I was 28
I wrote 'The Notebook.'
But the neat thing about those first two
that were never published was that
when I went into writing 'The
Notebook' I knew I would finish.
- [Cara] Yeah.
- You know, that was
never a question that I...
The only question I had
was whether I could make
the story good.
And I had all the time in the world.
- Well, well done.
- And I had no deadline.
Thanks.
Right.
- People liked it.
(audience cheering)
- Yeah.
- People like many of them.
But your latest book is
set in the world of music,
which we love.
- Yeah.
- Yes.
- So why did you choose that?
- Oh, there a few reasons.
One was, I was always
interested in the idea
that falling in love is a little bit like
creating the perfect song,
in that the notes have to be just right.
The melody just has to be just right.
The movement has to go.
And if everything works out
you're left with this
beautiful song on the one hand.
Or you're left with a really
beautiful relationship.
And you know, wrong notes
can ruin the whole thing.
- Yeah.
- And so when you have
something that works in love
and then something that works in music,
I think they're very parallel.
And so I kind of wanted to explore that
in part of the story.
- Yeah, because you've written so many
so that's why I was wondering
why you went with this theme.
- It's also different, right?
- Yeah.
- It's something that
I haven't done before.
- Yeah.
- But in this, I wanted the
two characters to fall in love
while in the process of creating music.
They literally write a song
together called, "Dreamland."
- Because I think sometimes
when you write a song with
someone, it's like making a baby.
- [Kelly] So vulnerable.
- Yeah.
- Again, we've gotta
stop talking about that.
I know.
I think someone wants a baby like.
'Cause she's talks about
making some babies over here.
No, but it is you.
It's such a vulnerable place.
Funny enough, I'm not
good at sitting in a room
and writing with people.
I'm not good at that.
I'm good at like doing it on my own.
- On own.
- Yeah.
If you see my name on it,
I've really just done lyrics,
usually and melody on my own.
'Cause I'm not really open.
It's a very-
- Lyrics I write by myself always.
But Melody, I need someone
to go stop adding things
'cause I'm constantly
like (indeterminable).
- Yeah.
But see that's a
relationship so you're right.
Yeah, you're right.
- When you get in the room.
- Well you know, so you
have these two people,
he generally writes music on his own
and then she struggles sometimes.
She's good with some of the
lyrics but can't get it right.
And it's a surprise to both
of them that it works so well.
And of course they're-
- I love that.
- Young and attractive
and they're at the beach-
- Yeah.
- And there's walks.
- I mean.
- They go kayaking and
then yeah, it all works.
And then of course
there's a whole other part
of the story too.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- (gasps) Okay.
- And it all comes together.
- [Kelly] I love it.
- That sounds amazing.
- And also because been to a movie,
what about the soundtrack?
That's amazing.
'Cause it's a musical
one and that's awesome.
- Yeah.
- It would be...
Obviously that's the plan.
- Yeah.
- It's already actually
been sold film Universal,
which is different from-
- Yeah, I imagine when
your pen hits paper.
- [Cara] Yeah.
- Then someone before
even reading the story
is like thank God, because
you're so talented at it
that people get excited about it.
It's an opportunity, and you
have such a huge fan base,
that people are already
excited when they know
you have a book coming out
and then they wanna see the movie.
There's already like a built-in fan base.
That's incredible.
- It is.
- [Cara] Yeah.
- Do you find any pressure in that?
- Yeah?
- Oh that's a great question.
Yes and no.
- Thank you.
I just gotten here.
- Right, right.
(audience laughs)
It's interesting when I sit down,
before you write first you
have to think of the story,
right?
- Yeah.
- And so before I decide what to write
I try to make sure that
the idea will be original
not only for a novel,
but also for a movie,
because I know that it might...
So it's gotta meet both of those.
So I throw stories away that I
say well it would be original
as a book but not as a film.
And that's happened.
And the best way to understand that,
and it's not what I've ever done,
but let's say I would never
write a novel with a love story
based on the Titanic.
- Right?
- Yeah.
- It probably didn't end well.
- Well it probably didn't, you know.
But certainly there's
not a book like that.
- They didn't make it.
- But everyone remembers the film.
So if I did anything similar,
it just wouldn't be original.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So lots of ideas get thrown away.
- Do you have to kind
of relinquish control
when it comes to becoming
a movie a little bit?
Not like let go of kind of the outcome
of what you may imagine in your head.
- You entrust it to someone, yeah.
- That's a very sweet way of saying it.
Of course you relinquish (laughs).
- (laughs) Yeah.
- And they bought it.
- You have to, but you're
like, I don't, I wanna...
- You literary sign a contract-
- But at this point though
- That say they could do anything.
- I know.
- You need to probably pick
and choose, so that's kind of awesome.
- Right.
It is.
And usually I work with
people, in fact always,
I worked with people who
liked the story in the novel.
- So that's right, yeah.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And my goal then at
that point is to just have
the best film that you can
'cause the novels are already done.
- [Cara] Yeah.
- And so even if that has
some changes from the book-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- To make the film better,
I'm generally okay with it.
- Interestingly enough, I
don't know if you do this
but when I write music, I
see a movie playing out.
There's so much imagery.
- Oh it's so visual.
Yeah.
- I can't not do it.
Imagery always naturally
happens whenever I'm...
It's like mini videos in my head.
- Great.
- Interesting.
- Yeah.
Well Nicholas Sparks latest novel
is called "Dreamland", everybody.
And it is out now.